my video today is going to be
a little bit different
fairly short i just want to share with
you this photograph
i came across this photo recently and it
was i just
i love it
this is
just a very
it's an interesting interaction
happening between these two
on the right the chimpanzee here is
sammy
he's nine years old
according to the information that i
found on the internet
to the left is zookeeper luke
boujovic
and i'm i guarantee i'm saying that
wrong he's serbian or i guess i should
say yugoslavian because this was back in
1988
back when serbia was yugoslavia
and sami had as the story goes sammy was
new at the zoo he was
as mentioned he was nine years old he
escaped and he ran away and he was
he had been playing an impromptu game of
king kong
all throughout the city
it was actually quite terrifying for him
people were chasing him trying to throw
nets at him
he scared a lot of people because even
at age nine a chimpanzee is strong
enough to rip a man's arms off no
problem
so
people did have reason to be frightened
luckily for sammy
the good people of yugoslavia did not
send airplanes with guns after him
instead they sent their version of mr
rogers to talk him down from his perch
you can't see it in this photograph but
there are hundreds of people watching
he escaped because he didn't like his
new zoo
maybe he missed his old friends maybe he
just didn't like his enclosure
he was having a rough time there you
know it's this is a zoo in yugoslavia
that didn't have a whole lot of money
by today's standards wasn't good at all
but and that's actually kind of
the thing back in the 80s
no matter what you think of zoos today
they
they were a lot worse i mean
the zoo systems they started out kind of
as freak shows you know and then over
time we realized that wow
these animals are really special we
should
we should treat them better so this is
in the 80s this is kind of in that
transition period where zookeepers are
starting to change how things are done
but of course
this was a communist country they
weren't doing super well at this point
in history and
resources were thin
this guy's enclosure was not a happy
place to be in he didn't like it he knew
the zookeeper
they were
friends sort of but for sammy at this
time in his life that's
the zookeeper is the only person he
really knew
all of his friends he had left from the
old zoo where he was born
there's a series of pictures here
actually you can see
man he's a beautiful chimpanzee look at
him
very very thick coat of fur it's kind of
unusual
and
he had been chased around you know
by people all day and it must have been
really nice for him to see his buddy you
know the one guy that he knows
buddy is the wrong word i mean it's like
the only it's the one familiar creature
in his world that's still around
everything was taken from him when he
when he left his last
zoo
supposedly he has a daughter
sammy has a daughter i don't know that
he was necessarily close with his
daughter or
uh
how how things were at that other zoo
but apparently he had already fathered a
daughter at age nine which is rare for
chimpanzees but it's not unheard of
usually between 9 and 15 the males are
ready to mate
for females it's a little bit later
but
what i read from this photograph and i
don't have any sort of message about
zoos or about
even biology really this is not a
biology lesson today it just
it feels like i understand what's going
on here right
you can look at this picture and you can
feel what's happening
he seems very upset about his situation
actually they both seem fairly upset
about their situation
this poor man's trying to convince this
chimpanzee that
uh
yeah i guess it sucks but
it's what it is
to the story sammy had spent the entire
day running around town
terrified
trying to find something
better
than where he came from and there wasn't
anything there was just scary things
everywhere there were angry people
and so he this look on his face right
now he's just realizing
maybe the zookeeper is right maybe
maybe the zoo is as good as it gets
he seems very defeated here
but also he seems very glad to have his
zookeeper friend
finally by his side after the whole day
of craziness
he's got
someone he knows at his side
and according to the article i read
this encounter ended with them holding
hands
and the zookeeper taking him leading him
to his car and they drove back to the
zoo
and all was well for a while
it eventually broke out again
and the second time
he ended up being tranquilized
and
then he didn't escape for several years
after that
he died at age 13 of intestinal issues
which
who knows what could have caused that i
mean all sorts of things really
you kind of want to blame it on like
poor diet
maybe a bad animal husbandry but
there are many things that can cause
intestinal issues
and that's pretty young for a chimp
chimps usually live about 33 years in
the wild
when i saw this picture i just wanted to
share it with you it's
3 48 in the morning so
uh i don't know maybe i'm a little bit
drunk in on sleepiness but i just felt
like this was a cool thing to share
there's just something poetic about this
even though it's it's like a sad story
it's kind of it just
it's drenched in misery really this this
photograph but also
this really
intense really genuine
interaction
now of course this is just a single
photo
maybe it just looks more poetic than it
actually is maybe sammy's just picking
his nose maybe the zookeeper's look of
concern on his face is really because
his pants split when he kneeled down
like this and he doesn't want everyone
to see
it is possible that i'm deeply
misinterpreting this photograph but
look at that
look at that expression that sami is
making
i could be completely misreading the
picture
but it feels like
humanity
expands at least a little bit
beyond our species
you